hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in chapters 9 through 11 of st. Anselm's
Proust loggia and he considers a key
question pertaining to theology but also
you could say to ethics very broadly and
it has to do with the divine nature
which he is attempting to explore
through using this notion of God being
that then which nothing greater can be
thought and so the conundrum that comes
up is one that many people of his own
time and from previous times and even up
to the present are often quite bothered
by it's this question about the
compatibility between two different
aspects or characterizations of what God
is like and one of these is in fact a
divine attribute so it names what God is
like all the other divine attributes and
that is justice God is not only
perfectly just according to Anselm God
is Justice itself God is the justice by
which other instances of Justice have
what makes them just they participate in
that divine justice so God is going to
be held to some pretty strict standards
and then on the other hand God is also
portrayed as being merciful being
merciful
in ways that go beyond even our
understanding of how merciful God ought
to be there's the amount of mercy that
God gives and then God gives yet more
and what does that mercy actually look
like as you pointed out in the previous
chapter chapter eight it's not as if God
just you know it's crying all the time
and feeling sad and all that no God is
merciful in in large part by forgiving
and by helping us to avoid the
consequences of what strict justice
understood in its own right would
actually impose on us miserable
screwed-up beings so there's a problem
there how can God have both of these at
the same time how can God be both
merciful and merciful beyond what human
beings are like and also superlatively
just to the wicked now why did I say to
the wicked or to the bad well because
God can be just to the good and not have
to forgive them because they're good
right God rewards the good people
according to their merits and you know
perhaps help them out along the way but
at least they did something right in the
case of the bad people it seems to be a
bit of a problem if you forgive somebody
aren't you letting them off the hook and
isn't that doing injustice to the rest
of creation or to the other people who
you don't forgive so it seems like mercy
and forgiveness violates a strict
understanding of divine justice and God
can't you know plead ignorance because
God is omniscient and God can't plead
incapacity because God is omnipotent so
this is a particularly huge problem you
know and some says how does the all just
and supremely just one do something that
is unjust what kind of justice is it to
give everlasting life heaven you know
eternal life to him who
merits eternal death so yes how how do
you good god save the wicked if this is
not just and you do not do anything
which is not just and he suggests at one
point that well maybe this is just a
mystery and Anselm is not the kind of
person who is going to remain content
with God's mysterious ways he wants to
explore them as much as possible so he's
going to provide us with some lines of
reasoning or argumentation and one of
these has to do with divine goodness
God would be less good if God was not
good to some bad people or perhaps good
to all bad people if God was only good
to the good what should be just fine
right being good to good people there's
nothing wrong with that and then being
you know mean or just or Stern or
however you want to put it to the to the
bad people who really have that coming
to them that would be fine God would be
good in doing so but God would not be as
good as God should God would not be
superlatively good God would not be good
in such a way that God would be that
then what's great nothing greater can be
thought the linchpin not only for the so
called ontological argument but
throughout the entirety of the prost
loggia whatever we conceive of you know
as as God it's going to be greater than
it's going to be that then which nothing
greater can be thought so we can imagine
a God who actually would be good to some
bad people that's got to be God so how
does the insolent parse this out he says
well it's it's better to be good not
just to the good but also to the good
and the bad
so in that case mercy looks like it
could stem from the divine attribute of
goodness and he says he who is good to
the wicked by both punishing and sparing
them is better than he who is good to
the wicked only by punishing them so you
are Merce
all these talking to God because you're
all good and supremely good it's perhaps
a parent why you should reward the good
with good in the bandwidth band what
indeed is to be wonder that is why you
would bestow good things on your wicked
and guilty creatures and he says well
this is because God is so good right so
this is where the fount of mercy flows
from now he has to go further than that
because at this point it seems like
maybe divine goodness is on one side and
then divine justice is on the other side
and maybe we'd have to give one of them
up so he says this divine goodness is
not only not opposed to or different
from the divine justice it actually is
in fact because it's a divine attribute
nothing apart from justice and a
coincides with justice so this allows
him to say that God is merciful not just
because God is good but because God is
supremely just so at this point what
Anselm is telling us is although we
originally conceptualized it as well
we've got mercy over here justice over
here there are two different things and
the you know merciful acts are going to
in some way abrogate or suspend or
contradict divine justice really mercy
is stemming from goodness justice and
goodness are essentially coterminous or
the same thing within God and so what
that means is that the divine mercy is
actually arising from stemming from you
could say ontological II caused by the
divine justice there is no contradiction
between the two and he tells us
something very interesting here that
again has to do with divine goodness why
is it good for God to be good to the
good and the bad is it just simply
that's that's what goodness means sort
of an indiscriminate giving of goodness
it goes beyond that by forgiving by
spare
literally park canari by not imposing
the penalty of justice on many people
many bad people God is able to give them
the opportunity and perhaps even certain
capacities or assistance with quitting
at least to some degree being bad people
and becoming good people so God is able
in some sense to add - you might say the
sum total of goodness within the
universe at least with respect to
rational creatures like human beings so
that by forgiving by showing mercy God
is actually making good people from bad
and some tells us and that would be also
compatible with justice so far so good
it seems like there not only is no
incompatibility we have some sort of
rational understanding of why God in
fact would be saving some people
forgiving some people who actually don't
deserve it and at the same time would
not be unjust in doing so but then we're
opposed with another question why these
people and not those people doesn't that
seem to be unfair if if it's better for
God to be good to the to the bad why
doesn't he just save everybody
isn't it unjust that he leaves some
people in the theological or ontological
lurch damaged you know off on the side
going to eternal death and he saves a
whole bunch of other ones even if he
just left one person there and everybody
else was screwed everyone else was was
doing well that one person was screwed
wouldn't that be improper wouldn't that
be unjust and Anselm says no that's the
wrong perspective to take you know why
does God punish some people and forgive
others is this justice yes because if we
consider both sides
he's just when he punishes bad people
actually deserve to be punished because
of their merits it
is fitting you know convent it in Latin
right it's appropriate to their merit so
it's also appropriate to the merits with
a good that they're not punished but
rather rewarded but it's also just when
God forgives why because it is the
thinning and he uses another you know
similar term to convent
not exactly the same thing but he says
that it is befitting to divine goodness
that he he does that he says here we go
said quia Bona Tati too I cone dekins
s it is befitting it is appropriate it
pertains to your own goodness
so either way to God is being just now
Ansem does concede that if we ask about
particulars if we say all right so some
people not save some people saved or
forgiving other people somehow merited
you know rewards and so they're going to
be given eternal life because they're
good people put them aside why these
people in particular
Anselm says well at that point when we
get down to specifics we can't find a
reason we we can't know why these people
but not others are forgiven are shown
mercy but we can know that it is
superlative Lee just for God to do that
we just don't enter enough into the
divine mind or reasoning or ever you
want to put it to be able to understand
why this unfortunate guy over here was
sentence down the basis of his merits
and this you know poor bastard over here
was forgiven and allowed to become
transformed into a good person and
thereafter rewarded so this is as far as
we can penetrate
into the understanding of the divinity
according to Ansel
you